MIDCOURT TOOK HIS TIME.
EY
HERE T
BEHIND THE BACK, BEHIND
ACCELERATES, OFF MOBLEY, PUTS IT
UP AND IN AND EV
BALL AND MOBLEY WITH A GOOD
CATCH AND ANICE LOOK AWAY PASS,O
THE BASKET OUT OF L.S.U.
GARLAND OVER THE SHOULDER. HE B
ONCHARGINGARKET THEM.
A BRIL
SO MANY TIMES, GARLANBY MARKETI
GARL TIMEOUT AND DARIUS
GARLAND ABOUT A CAVS WILL DEFINO
USE DEFENSE.
>> John: OKORO RUNS THE THE
MONEY.
>> Austin: OFF DRIBBLE, DOWN TO.
LONG
AWAY FROM THE BODY.GARLAND MAKES
ALL OF A SUDDEN HE GOT A FEW FA
HAIRIRURE.
STRIPPED CLARKE.
THE AN OUR FIRST
BREAK.  DAVIS
THE CAVALIERS SCORED THE LAST 6
POINTS.
A DANDY PASS BYMOBLEY.
OH MYWHO-EE.NEGATIVE.
>> John: GARLAND.
WHAT A
BELIEVE ME.
IN TRAFFIC WITH THE LEFT HAND  .
DARIUS GARLAND LOVES HIS NEW BIG
MAN.
>> YES HE DOES, BECAUSE ALLNOT A
SHOOTING FOULPLAY THIS
PICK. ROLL. NOBODY THERE
FLUSH. THIS HAS
OUT COMES THE CAVALIERS THAT
BACK TO  TO RECOGNIZE THAT HE
>> GARLAND, STOPS.
FIREPORT.
GARLAND DOWN THE LANE.
AND ALLEN PUTS IT TO THE CAVALI
THIS FIRST  TO
GARLAND, SHOVELED TO MOBLEY,
>> John:
FINAL QUARTE LED BY MITCHELL.
RUDY GOBERT GETS TRIPPED
QUARTER AS BEVERLY GETS BY
GARLAND RELAYS
LAP.
>> Jim: YOU CAN SEE WHY
VEN THOUA
SMALLER
PUTS IT UP AND HAND. AS ALWAYAY